soir en duplex violaine guérin médecin
endocrinologue bonsoir alors justement
pour commencer je vais me tourner vers
vous docteur violaine guérin olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé a parlé
d'un virus qui circulent trop vite dans
les métropoles en même temps un
frémissement positif dans d'autres
métropoles
il faudra attendre lundi pour savoir où
pas si paru si paris bascule en alerte
maximale alors comment le comprendre
ça chauffe mais la situation reste sous
contrôle où finalement le pays prend du
retard et risquent une perte de contrôle
dans les semaines à venir
alors je suis médecin en ville et je
voulais préciser que nous ne sommes pas
du tout en train d'observer cette
panique générale qui est annoncé il me
paraît extrêmement important que la
france très rapidement modifie ces
seuils d'amplification des tests pcr
comme l'a fait récemment parce que on
est dans des statistiques qui ne
correspondent pas du tout à ce que l'on
voit nous en ville alors on parle donc
de l'hôpital donc quand le midi la santé
parle d'un million de tests ils sont nés
il s'en est félicité ça ne suffit pas
alors ce serait beaucoup trop de tests
en fait pour faire des tests simplement
chez les personnes symptomatique donc
aujourd'hui on fait du dépistage à tout
va avec des tests qui comprennent
beaucoup de tests faux positifs et des
patients asymptomatiques etc
donc on n'est pas du tout dans une
logique médical correct aujourd'hui
d'évaluation de la situation sanitaire
nous nous les médecins de terrain nous
pouvons comparer à ce qui se passait en
février mars avril où effectivement on
voyait des patients tous les jours sous
franco vide etc
aujourd'hui ce n'est absolument pas la
réalité et on manipule beaucoup les
est donné il ya même des erreurs de
données puisque j'ai lu il ya quelques
heures un article montrant des erreurs
dans les saisies de santé publique
france a priori on a vu qu'à marseille
l' ars paca à donner des évaluations qui
se ne se sont pas avérées justes donc il
ya beaucoup de deux à la fois je pense
d'incompétence d'erreurs et puis surtout
la santé et manipulé actuellement pour
prendre des données et des mesures qui
sont extrêmement liberticide et qui ne
se justifie pas médicalement
alors qu'on a des traitements en phase
précoce qui existe
on a certes des problèmes de tension
spital hier mais qui ne correspondent
pas à la réalité de l'épidémie qui sont
des tensions qui sont liées à la
destruction de notre système de santé
depuis des années on a encore appris
qu'on avait supprimé trois mille cinq
cents lits en 2019
ça c'est quelque chose qui se poursuit
depuis des années et quelque part moi je
suis presque un petit peu en colère par
rapport à aux médecins hospitaliers qui
certes ont manifesté fait des grèves etc
mais qui a réduit carrément arrêté de
travailler depuis un certain temps pour
que l'état français sauvent le système
de soins de santé français et arrête en
détruire